[Music]
it's time for more cheesy spookiness
with Halloweentown to a far better
follow up from the last lame movie with
much better acting much better effects
much better visuals does that make it
good haha let's not say if you think we
can't take back the Cromwell's are
finally throwing a Halloween party you
didn't even invite over there grandma
this is being done because the mother
has no intention of the kids ever going
back to spooky old Halloween town but
that of course changes when an evil boy
comes into the mix steals the grandma's
magical book and uses it to literally
suck all the color out of Halloweentown
yep all the crazy ghouls and weird
goblins are now being replaced with
normal people
bland attitudes and a black and white
landscape to make things worse the boy
which we now find out is the son of the
villain from the last film takes their
grandma once again out of commission
meaning it's up to the kids to figure
out how to set everything right so for
the most part everything is a big
upgrade first of all look at these
effects okay they're not phenomenal but
they're pretty damn good for that time
period the black and white filters are
almost as good as Pleasantville and they
don't just turn everything black and
white there's still hints of color
around so it's not visually
uninteresting to look at and the color
that is and they're really pops a lot
more the acting is also a lot better
unlike the last film where you're
constantly trying to not snicker at how
awkward the performances are here I
don't know if they got a new director or
just more time has passed for them to
get used to their roles but everybody
seems much more on track okay they're
not phenomenal performances but they're
not in any way distracting the story
allows for a lot of fun ideas - like did
you know to undo a spell you literally
just save the spell backwards that's
kind of smart and it also leads to some
good problem-solving as they said a word
that apparently reversed the spell so
they know that they say a backwards
that'll be what the spell is so they
have to retrace their steps remember
what they said say the words backwards
it's actually kind of neat there's also
a place where all your missing items go
you ever miss the remote or your earring
or something like that this place in
Halloweentown hasn't but the owner got
infected by the spell - so he has
everything clean and now they can find
everything which is against the idea it
has to be lost in order to be found and
it's kind of creative the world's
themselves look a lot better there's
much more of a visual art design and
it's more colorful and interesting but
the major downside is they don't go to
that many places a lot of the movie is
them just staying in one spot talking to
each other trying to figure out what to
do and because the spell is D monster
izing everybody you don't really get to
see that many monsters either that is
until the end they have this really cool
idea where the bad guy cast the spell
and whatever masks they're wearing at
the Halloween party they become that
creature the monsters become monsters
the vampires become vampires it's really
neat but the problem is this happens in
the climax why didn't this happen in the
middle of the film a lot of these
makeups are very creative and goofy and
fun again why weren't we allowed to see
him more as cheesy as the makeup was in
the first film they were at least
creative and allowed us to see a lot of
them here it's all kind of kept until
the last couple minutes and they're cool
but for what we call Halloween town I
expect to see a little bit more
Halloween imagery so I guess that is the
one thing the first film has over this
one is that it does have a little bit
more variety in locations and weird
makeup designs and so forth but for
everything else this movie does things a
lot better the ideas are more
interesting the acting is more
interesting the visuals are more
interesting I feel like they got a
bigger budget to work on this but they
still had a lot of time restraints so
they had to move things around and maybe
they only had certain locations for a
certain amount of time and I don't know
maybe not but that's what it feels like
watching it though they're given a lot
more you're still always made aware of
the limitations but for the most part I
think they did the limitations okay at
least better than the last one
what I watch it again no is there
anything really in it for adults not
much but as kids TV movies go I think
it's got enough to be imaginative not a
glowing review but a positive one if you
got a kid that's interested just like
Halloween candy it's perfect
junk food
[Music]
you